clic clic waouh tu fais ip à bien le
clic merci à paul toi ça lui rendre sa
wii et on devrait on verra comment tu
vas attend synthes et cela pour que tu
me manques je veux juste vraiment savoir
comment tu vas enfin sarah très bien
pourquoi ça a l'air d'aller
ok ornements truc ça marche pas avec
tout le monde quel truc mais faire ça
non non non je vais t'expliquer tu me
julien j'ai pas bien là finalement ça va
pas bien
hop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler santé mentale
parce que c'est important d'en prendre
soin et parce qu'on n'en prend pas
autant soin qu'on devrait mais avant de
commencer je vais vous raconter une
histoire une histoire qui illustre
parfaitement le problème
cette histoire c'est l'histoire de
sylvie on né le 29 décembre 2016
sylvie a passé noël avec une partie de
ses enfants et de ses petits-enfants et
elle s'apprête à fêter ses 68 ans heavy
c est ce qu on appelle une femme forte
elle a dédié toute sa vie à aider les
autres là elle est à la retraite depuis
un an et elle a plein de projets mais
sylvie a un problème on lui a découvert
un lymphome cérébrale c'est à dire une
forme rare de cancer du cerveau
elle est rentrée à l'hôpital très très
vite on lui a fait tous les examens
nécessaires elle a eu tous les
traitements possibles et au bout de
quelques mois
les médecins lui ont dit qu'elle était
quasiment en rémission qu'après une
dernière chimio et serait guéri sa prise
en charge médicale a été hyper efficace
parce que normalement dans ce genre de
maladie l'espérance de vie est un ouf
donc génial sauf que sylvie à un autre
problème
elle est hyper diminué physiquement par
les signaux et par les séquelles d'un
examen qu'elle a subis et qui l'a laissé
paralysé d'un côté du corps là aussi
elle récupère hyper vite mais elle le
vit mal
elle vit très mal sylvie c'est une boule
de force et d'énergie et elle supporte
pas de se voir comme ça elle est sombre
elle est très très sont les médecins qui
s'occupent d'elles ont été mis au
courant qu'elle n'allait pas bien du
tout ivy donne quelques médicaments la
psychologue passe la voir une fois ou
deux max mais elle n'a pas de vraie
prise en charge si et sylvie va de plus
en plus mal on est le 29 décembre 2016
sylvie est quasiment guéri de son cancer
du cerveau
mais sylvie se jette par la fenêtre de
sa chambre d'hôpital et elle meurt sur
le coup
sylvie c'était ma mère elle est morte
guéri parce que on a soigné son corps
mais qu'on a négligé sa santé mentale
elle est morte parce qu'on a ignoré sa
souffrance psychologique des histoires
comme ça il y en a des milliers
j'en ai plein qui me reviennent de
l'époque où je travaillais
mais des histoires comme celle là c'est
juste la partie spectaculaire donc la
partie visible d'un phénomène qui touche
tout le monde de façon plus discrète
mais tout aussi dramatique et tout ça ça
vient d'une espèce de représentation
très largement admise qui voudrait que
la santé c'est le corps et que la santé
mentale au mieux ses accessoires au pire
c'est pas l'important sauf que c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche et la crise
sanitaire qu'on est en train de
traverser depuis plus d'un an
ça a bien mis tout ça en lumière les
troubles du sommeil les sentiments de
solitude et de mal-être les états
anxieux les états dépressifs tout ça ça
a augmenté de manière très significative
depuis le début de la pandémie
et si au départ ça pouvait être lié à la
peur du virus ce qui pose problème
maintenant c'est les mesures sanitaires
ont mis à l'arrêt tous nos loisirs
pratiquement et qui ont diminué voire
carrément anéanti nos interactions
sociales
d'ailleurs quand on regarde les chiffres
des troubles psychologiques on voit
qu'ils sont liés avec les dates de
confinement de couvre feu etc
et j'ai même pas besoin de rappeler la
souffrance psychologique des étudiantes
et des étudiants
attention toutes les classes d'âge sont
touchées et c'est vrai que le fait que
ça touche aussi fort les jeunes ça
marque forcément
globalement on est tous d'impacter et on
va tous s'en sortir enfin on peut tous
s'en sortir parce qu'il ya des moyens de
prendre soin de sa santé mentale
mais il ya trois problèmes d'abord tout
ce qui entoure la santé mentale
les psys et c'est encore en 2021 ça a
une image négative péjorative tabou
d'ailleurs quand on traite quelqu'un de
cinglé ou de schizophrènes c'est pour
l'insulter alors que je suis presque sûr
qu'on vous a jamais traité de
diabétiques ou d'insuffisance rénale
pour vous faire de la peine
ensuite comme je les dis juste avant il
ya cette idée que la santé c'est le
corps et que le psychisme c'est un peu
accessoire alors qu en fait pas du tout
et en plus les deux sont intimement liés
j'en avais déjà parlé dans une vidéo je
sais pas si vous vous rappelez je vous
remets le lien dans la description et
j'ajouterais qu'il ya une dimension
sociale à la santé
évidemment ça jouer en ce moment on s'en
rend particulièrement bien content et
pour finir
et là encore la crise sanitaire a mis un
bon gros coup de projecteur là dessus
prendre soin de sa santé mentale ça
coûte cher ça coûte même trop cher pour
un certain nombre d'entre nous parce
qu'il y en a
ou qui doivent y renoncer pour des
raisons financières en fait ces trois
problèmes c'est un peu le même gros
problème la santé mentale
c'est un peu honteux c'est pas important
donc c'est pas remboursés enfin tout est
pas à rembourser mais ça on va y revenir
après avant ça on va faire un petit
point qui est important en répondant à
une question pour prendre soin de sa
santé mentale
on va voir un psy mais c'est quoi un psy
bas en psy ça veut rien dire enfin ça
veut dire plein de trucs parce que c'est
une abréviation qui peut désigner
plusieurs métiers un ou une psychiatre
déjà c'est à dire un médecin spécialisé
en santé mentale
exactement comme un ophtalmo et
spécialiste des yeux c'est le seul psy
qui peut poser un diagnostic parce qu'il
est médecin
c'est à dire qui peut vous dire voilà ce
que vous avez c'est ça ça s'appelle
comme ça et ça se soigne comme ça c'est
aussi le seul qui peut vous prescrire
des médicaments et c'est le seul qui est
annoncé par la sécu à ou une psychologue
c'est à dire une professionnelle qui est
pas médecin mais qui est quand même
spécialisés en psychologie donc en santé
mentale
c'est une profession qui est réglementé
pour avoir le droit de se dire
psychologue
il faut avoir une licence et un master
mention psychologie un ou une
psychanalyste c'est à dire une personne
qui pratique une forme de thérapie
particulière qui s'appelle la
psychanalyse mais là par contre la
profession et le titre de psychanalyste
c'est pas réglementée par la loi
il ya des formations mais pour pouvoir
s'installer en tant que psychanalyste
dans l'absolu il faut juste avoir suivi
soi même une psychanalyse dernier psy
mais vous allez voir qu'on fait on vient
d'en parler le ou la psychothérapeute
ben là ça veut juste dire quelqu'un qui
soigne les troubles psychologiques c'est
quelqu'un qui va vous suivre vous
accompagne et vous aider si vous en avez
besoin ça peut être un psychiatre
même si tous les psychiatres font pas de
psychothérapie ça peut être un ou une
psychologue ça peut être ici qu'analyste
etc après il ya d'autres professionnels
de la santé mentale qui existent comme
les infirmiers et les infirmières si par
exemple mais globalement quand on parle
de psy on parle de ses trois métiers là
alors qu'ils allaient voir et quand pour
répondre à cette question on va laisser
de côté les psychanalystes
c'est juste des psychothérapeutes qui
utilise une certaine forme de thérapie
particulière vous pouvez la suivre ou
pas la suivre et pour rester génériques
va se concentrer sur les psychiatres et
les psychologues et la réponse vous
l'avez déjà un petit peu du coup vous
pouvez aller voir un psychiatre pour
qu'il fasse un diagnostic sur votre
santé mentale pour qu'il vous prescrive
un traitement si vous en avez besoin et
éventuellement pour qu'ils vous suivent
en psychothérapie
si c'est quelque chose qui pratique et
vous pouvez aller voir un ou une
psychologue pour suivre une
psychothérapie mais vous serez pas
remboursés et on parle quand même de
séance autour de 50 à 80 euros facile
pour être tout à fait précis
si vous allez chez un psychiatre que
vous êtes envoyé par votre médecin
traitant que vous avez déclaré à la sécu
etc
vous serez remboursé 2 32 euros sachant
que chez les psychiatres comme chez un
certain nombre d'autres médecins c'est
pas partout les mêmes prix il y en a qui
font des dépassements d'honoraires et la
consultation elle peut monter à 100 120
euros surtout si vous êtes à paris
si vous avez une mutuelle éventuellement
elle peut compléter sa il faut vous
renseigner
et si vous y allez sans passer par votre
médecin traitant
c'est encore moins bien remboursées sauf
si vous avez entre 16 et 25 ans là c'est
pas obligé de passer par le médecin
traitant
pour les autres le remboursement ça
tombe à 11 euros 50 et donc les
psychologues bah c'est pas du tout
remboursés
dans tous les cas ça fait cher surtout
si vous y allez toutes les semaines
alors pourquoi pourquoi les
psychothérapies chez les psychologues
sont pas remboursés je veux dire quand
vous avez une entorse
vous allez chez votre médecin et hiboux
diagnostic une intense et il va vous
prescrire un traitement peut-être des
médicaments contre la douleur etc
mais pas sûr par contre il va sûrement
vous prescrire des séances de kiné pour
remettre votre cheville et un peu
d'aplomb la consolider la renforcer et
pour éviter que ça recommence et les
séances de kiné
elles sont remboursées les psychologues
c'est un peu les teens et de la santé
mentale quand il ya quelque chose qui va
pas laisser ans ça permet de consolider
un peu tout ça pour permettre que ça
s'arrête et éviter que ça recommence
donc pourquoi on n'aurait pas le même
système
si un médecin nous prescrit une
psychothérapie si un médecin vous
prescrit des séances elles sont
remboursées
à vrai dire la réponse elle est un peu
philosophique comme on en a déjà parlé
la psy c'est un peu à part comme ça sans
aucune raison
mais c'est comme ça mais il ya aussi une
autre raison les autorités sanitaires
elles sont pas idiote l ont bien compris
que c'était complètement incohérent ne
pas rembourser des soins qui sont aussi
importants donc en partant du constat
que la dépression par exemple ça se
soigne beaucoup mieux avec les séances
de psychothérapie qu'avec des
antidépresseurs dont il dépresseurs dont
la consommation par ailleurs a explosé
et partant du constat que la raison pour
laquelle les gens vont pas chez le psy
c'est parce que c'est trop cher
l'assurance maladie a lancé une
expérimentation dans plusieurs
départements pour tester le
remboursement des séances de
psychothérapie mais à l'heure où je vous
parle c'est resté au stade
d'expérimentation locale parce que ça
coûte cher ça ça c'est sûr il faut juste
se demander si c'est mieux de continuer
à être parmi les champions d'europe de
la consommation de médicaments
psychotropes et si c'est ok de laisser
se dégrader la santé mentale des gens
juste parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens
de se soigner
donc la base c'est déjà de démystifier
la santé mentale tout le monde à des
entorses juste une fois dans sa vie ou
plusieurs fois pareil avec la souffrance
psychologique on est à toutes et tous le
droit au moins une fois dans sa vie ou
plus souvent bas il n'y a pas plus de
honte à aller chez le psy pour ça que
chez le kiné pour une entente depuis
quelque temps il ya jamais eu autant de
coach de vie de coach en développement
personnel etc
ça c'est bizarre ça ça passe crème et
pourtant des fois bon bref là en fait un
psy ça devrait au moins passer aussi
bien que ça non pour casser un certain
nombre d'idées reçues sur la santé
mentale je vous mets dans la description
de la vidéo un lien vers un podcast que
j'ai enregistrée qui parle de ça et qui
parle aussi de comment aider un proche
qui va mal
par exemple l'idée c'est d'arrêter de se
dire les psy c'est pour les fous déjà
fou ça veut rien dire faudra qu'on en
parle ces jours en fait là on parle
juste de se soigner quand il ya quelque
chose qui nous fait souffrir
après on l'a vu c'est vrai que
financièrement ça peut être compliqué
petit truc à savoir on peut avoir accès
à des soins psy gratuit c'est possible
dans les centres médico psychologiques
par exemple les cmp dans lesquelles il
ya toute une équipe d'infirmiers
infirmière de psychiatres de
psychologues et d'assistants sociaux etc
tout est pris en charge par la sécu et
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avancer le prix
des séances en fonction de l'endroit où
vous habitez vous dépendez d'un cmp
précis il faut prendre rendez vous et
vous vous doutez bien que vu que c'est
gratuit il ya un peu d'attentes mais une
fois que c'est parti
c'est parti de manière plus ponctuelle
n'hésitez pas à appeler les numéros de
téléphone de soutien psychologique
il y en a plein y'en a plein des
différents en fonction des raisons pour
lesquelles vous appelez ça peut faire du
bien globalement c'est un cliché mais
c'est la vérité par les cantons va pas
bien c'est important
mettre des mots sur un problème ça force
à réfléchir à ce problème à le sortir de
sa tête pour l'expliquer à quelqu'un et
ça permet de mieux le comprendre
soi-même souvent en plus ça libère ça
soulage
et puis la personne qui est en face de
vous elle peut trouver les mots qui vont
vous rassurer elle peut vous aider à
trouver des débuts de piste des débuts
de solution juste attention en parler
avec des amis avec des proches
c'est bien c'est important mais ça doit
pas vous empêcher d'en parler aussi avec
un psy d'abord parce que c'est son
métier
donc il va avoir une analyse plus fine
ensuite parce que on dit pas la même
chose à un proche qu'on va continuer à
voir tous les jours et avec qui on a des
implications émotionnel et à un psy qui
est un professionnel donc est neutre et
qui est juste là pour ça al'inverse un
proche vu qu'il est impliqué dans votre
relation
justement ça va un petit peu le
détourner de l'objectif principal qui
est de vous aider à aller mieux vous
parce que forcément il va recevoir des
infos il va penser à lui aussi donc
parlé à des proches
oui mais pas seulement dernier petit
conseil
sachez qui a tout un tas de techniques
thérapeutiques très différentes qui
marche plus ou moins bien sur tels ou
tels soucis psychologiques il ya des
thérapies courte d'autres qui sont plus
longues certains utilisent des
techniques cognitivo-comportementales
d'autres l'hypnose il ya la psychanalyse
dont on a déjà parlé il y en a plein
là aussi je vous mets un lien dans la
description vous irez jeter un oeil
l'idéal évidemment c'est de choisir
celle qui marche le mieux
sur ce qu'on a et sur notre personnalité
demandez conseil soit à votre médecin
soit à un psychiatre ou quand vous
prenez rendez vous avec un
psychothérapeute ou une psychothérapeute
posez peut-être la question au téléphone
la première fois que vous appelez et
pour finir je voudrais que vous pensiez
au maubourg suite
c'est un mélange entre bourse et
poursuites
non je déconne comme ça fait un moment
que je parle je voulais juste être sûr
que vous suiviez encore allez suivez
encore juste un tout petit peu je fais
un petit résumé
et après c'est fini en attendant qu'on
normalise le fait d'aller voir quelqu'un
quand on en a besoin
en attendant qu'on arrête de dire qu'on
va voir quelqu'un d'ailleurs on va voir
un ou une psychothérapeute c'est pas un
gros mot
c'est en nommant les choses aussi qu'on
l'ait démystifie et qu'elle devienne
naturel
en attendant que les séances les
psychologues soit remboursée parce qu'il
faudra bien que ça arrive
et le plus tôt sera le mieux en
attendant qu'on ait une vraie politique
de prise en charge de la santé mentale
et pas juste des chèques psy et des
numéros verts convient dé pandémie
en attendant qu'on ait droit à un check
up d'évaluation psychologique annuel
pris en charge à 100% par exemple un peu
comme pour les dents parce que dans les
deux cas des fois il ya des trucs qui
vont pas mais on s'en rend pas compte
alors on se fait pas suivre et en
général ces trucs-là plus est pris tôt
mieux c'est en attendant tout ça
déjà soyons attentifs les uns aux autres
prenons des nouvelles les uns des autres
demandons pour de vrai aux gens comment
ils vont mon petit conseil perso demandé
deux fois genre salut comment ça va le
truc de routine et juste après et en
vrai
comment tu vas ça montre que c'est une
vraie question c'est pas juste une
formalité ou de la politesse salon que
vous voulez vraiment savoir
donc ça autorise l'autre à répondre
vraiment et puis prenant soin de nous
mêmes alors c'est cool d'avoir un corps
qui fonctionne bien ça c'est sûr mais si
c'est pour travailler que du mal-être et
de la souffrance psychologique c'est pas
vous je vous ai mis plein de liens dans
la description des vidéos sur le sujet
mais aussi des infos pour trouver des
petits gratuit ou pas trop cher près de
chez vous jetez un oeil
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mais genre vraiment mettez vous bien et
surtout
portez vous bien